I love America more today than I did on
May 22nd but when I go back to Iowa it
will not be as a presidential uh
candidate I am suspending my campaign I
I think the voters uh who are the most
remarkable people on the planet have
been really clear that they're telling
me not now Tim I don't think they're
saying Trey no but I do think they're
saying not now and so I'm going to
respect the voters and I'm going to hold
on and keep working really hard and uh
look forward to another opportunity this
is really mature it's funny as Trey gy
there former Congressman Trey gy who now
in Fox News he tries to push Scott and
he says no come on what are you talking
about you're from South Carolina we're
coming up on the South Carolina race
you're crazy why would you drop out now
and Tim Scott says yeah because I'm not
going to win